yeah it's absolutely crazy how many
underhanded techniques that they're
using simultaneously while tracking
everyone's viewpoints tracking
everyone's opinion and then slowly
nudging in a direction that they want
you to perceive that they want you to
think this is why I think we have to be
very careful on on and and think
critically about what we see on social
media algorithms because those are also
highly manipulated as Facebook works
with the state department works with
Intel agencies to specifically curate
information as they were even doing
psychological uh studies there trying to
manipulate people's emotions to see how
far they could go just by simply
deciding on what to show people and what
not to show people I actually talked to
cast sunstein I brought his own document
to him and I said look you're talking
about doing all these covert underhanded
really immoral things to control the
narrative and the discourse in this
country and he said I never said it
it's right here buddy he never and again
totally denied it this is the game they
play